[Music]
welcome to this session about CI CD in
serverless and multi environments this
is a a topic that we are very passionate
about because we've seen that good CI CD
makes a big difference makes all the
difference when it comes to dev velocity
in an organization my name is martin
omander and i'm a developer advocate in
google cloud and I'm Adam Ross I'm a
engineer in developer relations in
Google cloud how many of you have ever
deployed to production from a documented
checklist raise your hands all right so
it's still a large number of people okay
how many of you built sassy icd pipeline
to automatically run tests or
deployments also a lot of good yeah
excellent well today we're going to
explore one particular organization's
journey into building their own pipeline
for automating these service operations
into the woods camping supply and before
we get too far you should know that this
is a made-up company their imaginary but
they've got some real-world problems
that we've seen actual organizations
face and as we go through what they've
their decision-making process in their
solutions
you might see some things that you can
bring back to your own organization as
solutions to your problems it's a shame
they're imaginary though they have such
a stylish catalog yeah well yeah I don't
know that's the wrong sheet of red but
one of their problems is they've had
slower and slower release velocity
because they don't have a good
automation pipeline in place so they
don't really know when things go wrong
and when they do they need to go
spelunking into the depths of their code
changes to find how to fix it so their
existing architecture has one monolithic
application and a number of micro
services each of them built as a server
list service and they need to figure out
how do we approach these individual
services and modernize how
they're operated we're gonna go straight
to a demo on what they end up doing by
walking through a change so the new
engineering manager has the friendly
failures initiative which requires that
all the error messages be friendlier and
we change and let's go ahead and create
a quick branch stage that code commits I
hope
let's watch conference Wi-Fi in action
that was really fast okay and so now
we're going to open a merge request in
get lab get lab is the version control
platform of choice for into the woods
github and bitbucket are all great
products this just happens to be with
into the woods uses and here we're going
to open a merge request which is roughly
the same concept as a pull request so
now that I've opened this merge request
it immediately shows us a nice page that
has the ability to open in a web IDE
check out the branch to explore it but
most particularly we see this this blue
circle here next to a pipeline a
pipeline is the set of jobs that are run
to ensure the quality and deployment
process and that's automatically kicked
off as soon as I open that merge request
and we can dig into that and see what
it's doing so here we have a visualized
display of different stages for this
pipeline running from testing all the
way up to the deployment and acceptance
and we're going to go deeper into the
individual stages for this later
drilling into just one of these we see
that there's a linting job for the
payment process and it's taking a little
time to initialize this workspace check
out the code
authenticate g-cloud and oh I have an
error well that's unfortunate I guess I
should fix that problem
and I also left a comma in the wrong
place so now that I've made a couple
fixes here I'll commit that
and we should see a new pipeline running
through I'm gonna just take a quick look
and make sure it's running yeah while
that cooks we'll go ahead and move along
can we go back to the slides so oops
Automation one might think it's about
computers but I'm here to tell you it's
about humans we all have our different
views of automation Junior James he is a
pretty junior developer at into the
woods he just wants to avoid frustration
and bureaucracy just bang out his code
and deploy it and have it be have it be
tested at work hard work process pori
she porush she's a lot as she's into
processes and scripts she has this idea
of observation should be about reducing
manual toil for the developers teamwork
tests she focuses on teamwork and she
wants everybody to have confidence in
the code and bring relief to the team
and finally the fourth person in the
engineering team here is Tseng he's the
CTO he wants to make it really clear to
everybody what they're supposed to do as
part of a release and we'll see these
four engineers here they are going to
discuss and build a CIC D pipeline and
we'll see the final result at the end of
the talk so that will have to go through
various things there are six major
decisions that they will need to make
from repo layout all the way through to
security they'll discuss C pros and cons
of various approaches and arrive at a
solution for each one repo layout first
one it's very its foundational before
you do this you can't release it do any
of the other pieces there are various
ways you can do repo management so for
example jr. James he's heard a lot about
micro services and being super agile and
he's like one repo per micro service
right they keep everything light and and
and really truly separated these micro
services poori notes that there are some
integration tests where would they live
test notes that there are some code
calling each other across microservices
where would the api specs for that live
also pouring all right rightly notes
that sometimes they need to run share
tools across the codebase that's really
easier to with a mono repo single
codebase and this of course easier to
share knowledge so after some discussion
james is convinced okay let's try the
mono repo approach what would that look
like the layout might be something like
this some files in the route a some dork
a docs folder and 2n test folder we have
the monolith they are moving from a
monolith to micro-services they haven't
the monolith it's still there so
micro-services are still there one
director further monolith once services
directory with all the different
micro-services have their own sub
directories they want to set up this for
growth right now their 5 microservices
that we'll have more in the future who
reviews code when you check code in well
james has found a cool feature in git
lab and it's in in other some other
tools as well you can add a code owner's
file that code owners file tells the
system who should be the auto assigned
reviewers for for any code that's
checked in and it also documents
ownership if you're just browsing the
code you know who to ask about a
particular piece of code good they've
decided to go with mono repo first
decision made one out of six done and
it's time to move on to number two so
next we have continuous testing getting
that test automation going on an ongoing
basis so that every change is carefully
measured and found to be acceptable to
move forward so do your developers might
commonly think oh I can just run the
test locally everything will work out
just fine but more senior engineers know
that can lead to inconsistent lis
running the tests and a lot of
difficulty making sure that you're
testing things the way they operate in
production running end-to-end tests on
cloud services can be
a little tricky on your laptop so
they're going to take their existing
work on building a testing pipeline and
extend it to these new service services
they've got and maybe some of those
automation engineers amongst you would
find that fun like par e it does sound
kind of fun doesn't it I I would want to
build this yeah so here is here we have
the master branch from the repo the
master branch is commonly used as a
release ready branch to which all
changes are merged now shortly after the
last release a bug-fix was begun this
branch has been in progress for a while
but in the interim someone else came
along fixed a problem and merged that to
master so when we look at this bug fix
branch ready to go unit test passing
James is excited to merge it tests knows
wait a second even though that test is
passing it's showing green there's a
logical conflict between what is now in
master and the change that James has
been working on thank goodness there was
an engineer on hands that has memorized
all the code changes that have gone on
for the last number of months so maybe
the solution here is to have trustworthy
tests if your automated tests aren't
reliable pretty much all the time
they're not worth that much because you
learn to disregard the results of
running those tests and so instead we
want to look into continuous integration
continuous integration takes this
continuous testing idea and focuses on
how to make sure that if you accepted
that change into your main line of code
what things still be passing this is
done by merging in the the master branch
here into the bug fix branch before
running those tests performing a code
integration not to be confused with an
integration test which is a bit of a
different beast
and as we explore needy to build that
pipeline what kind of tools should we
use well one of the most important
features that you might have for your CI
CD system would be a configuration as
code approach having the definition of
those jobs and all the operations
committed to your code repositories so
that the entire development team and any
ops engineers and anyone else around
that technical neighborhood can see
those changes and weigh in on what they
constitute and make sure that you're
practicing a good and integrated DevOps
sort of culture now as we've mentioned
this team is using git lab and they're
going to continue to use that for these
new services but in the future maybe
they'll outgrow gitlab maybe there'll be
some other considerations and they'll
consider other products such as circle
CI Travis Jenkins or cloudbuilt which is
a product in GCP a simple get lab
testing pipeline is made of yeah Mille I
bet a lot of you here we're thinking oh
serverless track we're safe from yeah
Mille but not always so here we have a
stage that includes a test stage it's
the only one for now but more will be
added later and every single job in a
test stage runs in parallel and our
initial jobs are linting and unit
testing linting is checking your code
syntax and unit tests are relatively
quick to run tests but we see that both
of these are running node they're both
running some implied service that
they're testing against so it's not
necessarily a good fit for a mono repo
it's not testing a bunch of different
services so let's expand on that linting
job now we have two linting jobs one is
testing a node service named relay
running a job at running the job inside
the relay subdirectory of the repo and
the other is linting a service built in
go running inside a payment subdirectory
and as James is observing this
multiplication of the jobs is going to
result in some slowdowns as more and
more services are added to the repo and
so making the pipeline a bit more
dynamic is going to help that process
using almost any
see ICD system you can introduce a
little dynamic logic and take advantage
of the fact that you're probably using
version control and you can run a
slightly complex commands such as this
get diff here to list all the files that
have changed and maybe only run the
tests that apply to those files and as
it happens get lab has a trick for that
in the configuration if you are running
your testing pipeline for a merge
request you can also specify to only run
that job if a file changes in a
particular subdirectory so here I I see
it as configured to only run if a file
in the relay service has some kind of
update and you might be thinking this is
getting a little complicated but that's
a trade off from going with a mono repo
the tooling is often a little behind on
that compared to having a service per
repository lastly when with the mono
repo and having all these services in
one repository there might be a tendency
to have some of the operations leak into
top-level directories or into this
configuration file well having those
operations defined in the world's best
known tasks run our bash scripts you can
get them isolated into those same sub
directories and make sure that you can
make sure that those responsible for an
individual service are also responsible
for all the details of the operations
and perhaps in the future this into the
woods dev team will look into moving to
something else that's a little bit more
sophisticated than - maybe using make
files or basil to run their run their
jobs and so by the time all of these
steps are built in we have a few
different stages potentially coming
together on just the testing pipeline a
pre-check here is showing the use of
shell check which is a utility that
applies linting checks to bash scripts
then tests running linting and unit
tests against each of the services and
builds running any builds for those
services that need a build process
alright so that was the end of step 2
now we two down four to go the next
decision the team at into the woods need
to make is how to manage automatic
deployments so there are a number of
ways to do deployments all the way from
how CTO sang did it before he was a CTO
when he worked in a start-up twenty
years ago through something that a
junior developer might do with scripted
development the team really though they
really want to focus on continuous
deployment to delivery rather than these
sort of semi manual approaches because
that leads to more reproducible
deployments and higher velocity so James
he is happy junior developer he checks
in a bunch of code it tests okay he
merges them ready to go on the release
train let's deploy to production
Tesla's hold on a minute how do we know
that this won't break
Perry has a solution we deploy it to
staging and we deploy it all the time to
staging and keep running tests there and
that way we can see if it would break if
we were to deploy it to production let's
see what that would look like so adding
deployment to this whole pipeline is
really just adding an additional stage
to the end of what we've already built
and that stage will include some new
deployment jobs these jobs bring with it
more yamo for us to look at a deployed
job definitely needs to run a deploy
process and that will probably involve
using g-cloud the command line SDK that
allows you to run operations against GCP
so we have a short handoff indication
for G cloud to cloud platform and we'll
go into more detail on that later in the
security section of the talk and then
under the script we're changing
directory into the relay service and
we're running our functions deploy for
that cloud function which probably
should be wrapped in a deploy script
itself but it's more clear this way that
that is not a very complicated scripts
necessarily now if you were going to
deploy instead a cloud run service which
you may have heard today across the
keynote
or other sessions you know that you're
dealing with serverless containers they
have a bit of a different deployment
model and so you are deploying a
container container image from Google
container registry to your cloud run
service but it is just the same a one
line command to make it happen so we
have added the new deployment jobs to
the end of our pipeline and so on every
change it will run through each of these
stages ultimately resulting in deployed
code all right three down three to go
the next step is environments how do we
deal with that at enter into the woods
so just a quick reminder what
environments are we have the
architecture that's the design right
what compute is in micro service what
storage is in a micro service
environments those are instantiation of
that architecture and we have them for
various uses like demo and tests and so
on alright so the team sits down to
discuss this party says let's minimize
admin administration by having all these
environments live in one GCP project
James is like no let's have them more
isolated let's have one environment per
GCP project we have many many many
projects well we need to look into the
pros and cons of each approach so if
each environment is a namespace here we
have canned stage 4 for the payments
micro service we have a payments compute
part anak payments data port payments
for QA and for stage so all in one
project it has certain advantages
parries right about that there is easy
access management you go into I am at
once and set that up it is also easy to
just list all your resources in a
project because it's all right there in
one project however there are some
global project settings that you might
have seen around regions and data app
engine datastore and so on that we need
set once per project
and that could be hard to make all the
difference of environments use those
single those global settings also it's
extra work to connect the compute and
the data for for these as a matter of
fact it could get so bad that you cross
wire and there's crosstalk between
environments so the team decides not to
have everything in one giant GCP project
well the alternative is every
environment is a GCP separate TCP
project so we have staging staging
project and we have a QA project so the
disadvantage of this is there's more
management of course we need to set up a
inter user access for every single
project another one is we had to keep
track of all these projects what's good
about this though is that we have really
strong isolation with no crosstalk
between environments so the team decides
to go with this approach now the
question is how do we avoid QA
bottlenecks in the old pre server last
days in into the woods there was one QA
environment and if you're working on a
branch you really wanted to test your
stuff on that and everybody was fighting
to get their stuff on there well new
environments everything is server lists
we can spin up as much as as many
environments as we want right well we do
need to keep track of them so maybe we
should give each developer their own
development environment and their own QA
environment rather than infinite
environments let's see what that would
look like so now that we have a plan
around the number of environments we
have production staging and then a QA
environment for each developer and a
development environment for each
developer so that they can experiment
and each of these environments is
related to the code changes in some way
production is going to be tagged off the
master branch when releases are cut and
master branch is going to automatically
deploy to staging and then individual
feature branches will deploy to QA
one of the challenges with this
arrangement of associating different
pieces different lines of code to
different environments is how the CI CD
system understands how to route that and
for that we have a bit of bash magic
here if the branch is master this the
this first part of the code says oh this
must be for stage and after the else
statement we're looking up a variable
from the environment to associate the
developer that pushed that last change
and that will map to that developers
environment
now you could hardwire that and say oh
we're going to just use the test
environment today but by providing that
little bit of separation it provides
space to then continue to expand this
later to perhaps have multiple
environments that that might be routed
to and so using this arrangement our our
earlier fix to the master branch is
going to automatically deploy to the
staging environment and bug fix number
one as it's going through is
troubleshooting cycles will be deployed
to James's QA environment once that is
approved to be merged into master it two
will be automatically deployed updating
the staging environments to the current
picture of what would happen if a
production release were tags and of
course once a release his tagged
production will be deployed all right
that was weave the team has decided on
four out of six
decision points the next one is
serverless
testing now this is a little different
than regular testing if you're testing
something you run in your your own data
center or on pram surrealist it's a
little bit of a different beast so there
of course different types of testing
junior developers think of unit testing
there's integration testing system
testing sang the CTO of course he thinks
more about end-to-end testing so we have
this whole spectrum of tests one isn't
better than the other some are really
useful to developers some are more
useful to business people we need some a
mix of all this different
types of testing how do we do that well
so here again we have bug fix one the
branch James has created he needs to
merge this in lets us see what testing
happens at each place in this scenario
so whenever he commits code that's the
heart James loves his code it's a heart
there is unit test and linting in the CI
workspace so this Estill has nothing to
do with server less or nothing to do
with cloud functions or clog run or
anything like that it's Auto deployed as
we saw is auto deploy - James - QA this
is James own QA environment and when
it's auto deployed their their automatic
system tests running there they run in
the context of server left so this run
on GCP and you can use all the GCP
services and databases and such they're
more bigger than unit tests then when he
merges into master
there are lint tests in the CSE system
and then it's auto deploy to staging
their their system tests run just like
on James - QA and there is also these
business more business focused
end-to-end tests or run is staging and
they're all branches are mixed up in
staging - so we test all of them so
they're broadly speaking there are two
types of testing environments here the
inside the CI CD system that's good for
simple testing like unit tests and
linting but when you actually test stuff
like serverless databases and making
calls and and you're exercising more of
GCP then you actually need to run those
tests on GC p so there are very
serverless options you've heard of you
may know of serverless functions cloud
functions you may know of app engine and
earlier today you heard about cloud
functions eclipse or a cloud run let's
go through and see how you would test
each one of these three servers compute
options testing a cloud function you can
do that locally the various ways of
doing it we really recommend if you want
to know more about testing cloud
functions locally you
you go to our co-workers to Stewart's
talk at on Thursday afternoon where he
will dig into more details around this
for unit testing you would create mock
HTTP requests and for system testing
well in that case you just you deploy to
GCP you'll get a URL and then your test
system hits that URL also worth noting
here test notes that it's good to have
sort of secondary more complex logic in
sort of secondary functions that aren't
directly called so that makes it easier
to just sort of unit test those and
troubleshoot those in a local
environment before you deploy everything
up to GCP on App Engine with the modern
runtimes on App Engine you tell you do
your local development to test using
your regular tools or like your regular
frameworks whatever you're using flask
Express etc unit testing there are more
libraries that walk out like task queues
and databases and things like that
and for system testing it's just like
cloud functions you deploy it to GCP you
get a URL and your test system hits that
URL also worth noting here is that App
Engine has been around for a long time
so there's lots and lots of content lots
of articles and blog posts by googlers
and non-googlers about how to how to
test it that was two of the service
compute options what about the third one
that we heard about earlier today
well since cloud run is new let's talk a
little about what it is to set the
groundwork for how we would test init
cloud run bridges the worlds of server
lists and containers providing a way to
run a containerized service server
lessly this means that you can build a
service in a pretty conventional way
wrap it in a container and deploy it if
you have no ops team like Tess's team
seems to have you can use managed cloud
run and otherwise you can have cloud or
non gke where you have a kubernetes
cluster underneath that your own ops
team can manage
and with this arrangement all the
considerations of how you would test a
container come into play for local
development and debugging you might run
your service locally using your standard
tools or you might choose to build that
container locally and run it so that you
are more closely simulating the
production environment for unit testing
you could also do the same run your unit
tests the way you normally would when
building code locally or you might also
build a container that's loaded up with
a number of development dependencies on
top of your the same production
dependencies that you have on cloud run
itself and in that case you can run the
unit tests there and have available any
of the system packages or other
resources that are part of your service
container for system testing much as we
were suggesting with cloud functions in
app engine go ahead and deploy your
service to cloud run it'll only be
running when you're testing it and
otherwise it will scale to zero and not
cause you troubles with all of the
different jobs that we've been looking
at with the CI CD system there is this
workspace that is spun up in which we're
running the linting checks running unit
tests and running G clouds to trigger
deployments and one of the problems you
might find are the performance concerns
of what it takes to initialize that
environments then run all the tests and
waiting for tests it's kind of a bummer
so one thing we can do is find ways to
optimize just how big those workspaces
are can we use a smaller container image
as part of that CI CD workspace to
initialize the environment now the if
the main Cloud SDK docker image that you
might use in a CI CD workspace is pretty
fully loaded it's based on DB n it has a
number of emulators and other things
that you might not need initially in a
service so you might want to go with a
more stripped-down approach using an
Alpine based image that's a lean
distribution of Linux that's really
popular in containers and add to it just
the pieces you need in this case for
your cloud run
and so the team here has built a
slightly customized version of the cloud
SDK pulling a static binary from docker
for the docker client and then adding
that to the official Alpine version of
the cloud SDK docker image and
installing the beta components which you
need in order to interact with the cloud
run service this can lighten the size of
this workspace container from around 700
megabytes to 120 megabytes and that can
save you a good minute of download time
on each of those jobs another problem
that can emerge from the particular way
we've outlined the system here is the
tendency to only trigger the tests when
a developer takes an action for
continuously evolving software that
seems fine you'll trigger the tests on
an ongoing basis and they'll continually
be exercised but for a mature service
that has already been built and is
running happily in the background
without anyone the wiser you won't
notice if bit rot sets in and makes that
service unstable if you were to try to
deploy it or try to issue changes and so
we running the deployment and testing
process on all your services is a
valuable way to make sure that they are
all staying in a healthy state whether
or not developers are actively working
on them so with this they've made
decisions in five out of the six areas
they're almost there the CI CD pipeline
is almost complete there is one area
that is very important you should not
forget about of course that is security
so the team sits down to discuss
security parra notes that she needs for
her the deployment scripts they need
some secrets to deploy to GCP test notes
that to hit the payments api that the
payment provider has they she needs a a
[ __ ] so here we see right away the
beginning of the discussion two types of
secrets
we have operational secrets on one hand
that deal with
managing me all their bills and CI CD
all that stuff and then we have runtime
secrets that are used by the runtime for
when it does what he's supposed to do at
that point James comes in and says well
we have secure source control this is
not an open source project just deploy
it all to source controls at this point
party has to come in and gently guide
James and say that this is not something
well the one does they could be
accidental disclosure I mean we don't
want developers to see the passwords and
then accidentally enter it somewhere
else we also have contractors working
from time to time at into the woods also
sometimes we share code with other
companies we could even have people
potentially break into our source
control system these secrets need to be
in a safer place than source control how
do we do this party has a proposal so
let's manage the operational secrets
separately from the runtime secrets so
everything starts with the repo right we
have source the source code there no
James no secrets in the source code then
that code gets pulled in by the CI CD
system and the CI CD system has the
operational secrets in it one
operational secret is the service key
that serves a count key that is used to
deploy code to GCP the other operational
secret is a the name of a storage bucket
that a Google Cloud Storage bucket and
that is deployed or set as an
environment variable in the runtime
environment so the runtime environment
can read it what does the runtime
environment do with the name of storage
bucket well when it needs a secret like
the API key for the payment API it can
go and hit that read from that cloud
storage bucket and and get that runtime
secret and what's cool about this is
that now that reading of the runtime
secret is managed through I am
in GCP which means it can be really
locked down who can read it James can't
read it for example para can't read
maybe none of the developers can read it
maybe it's only the the CTO Tseng who
can read this or and the runtime
environment so setting up this
environment means operational secrets
runtime secrets separately let's talk
about how those operational secrets are
put into the CI CD system in gitlab it's
easy you just enter them in the web UI
this means there is no file sitting
around with these secrets as soon as you
have a file it's very dangerous because
somebody might accidentally check it in
write in this way somebody types them
into the web UI nobody saves them
anywhere once you type these in let's
see where they go next so if we look at
the particular variables we have here
the third one down is the service
account key this is a key associated
with a service account from I am and
it's been entered here in a
base64-encoded way that way if anyone
accidentally looks at it takes a
screenshot echoes it out to a terminal
leave they've not accidentally seen it
it's a nice security through obscurity
and so using that every single job that
runs in the CI CD system can then expand
on that key taking that environment
variable decoding it and then using that
to authenticate g-cloud so that it can
go on to pretend to be that service
account as it goes through and runs any
deployment or other commands that you
need to run now as powering notes here
you might find that this is a little bit
easier if you were running from cloud
builds because with cloud build instead
of needing to manage this key separately
you can instead grants permissions to
the cloud build service account directly
and it will operate with that no
additional keys needed so once you have
this service account what exactly do you
do to give it those accesses all the
permissions that it needs to one builds
and deployment
and perform other operations you could
give it the project owner or editor a
role that's the easy button way to do it
but in that case if anything were to
expose that key the blast radius of that
would be encompassing almost all the
things that can be done with your DCP
project yes I'm good it could just take
down the production environment with
that key right there just delete it yeah
delete it so instead a least privilege
approach is much better figure out
exactly which roles and cloud storage
bucket eels you need to have and assign
them to the service account that way you
know that you've got the minimum
exposure what's more since we've charted
this course of every environment being
its own GCP project we might want to
have a central repository for things
like build artifacts and and this
service account so that we can have one
central source of authority and then
deploy into each of those other
environments in that case we're going to
need to collect all of the different
roles and permissions for the deployment
process of shipping resources shipping
cloud functions into stage and
production and give that to the service
accounts on a cross-project basis this
can be done by identifying the email
address of the service accounts and
adding it like a normal user to other
projects for runtime secrets we've
charted this course of using a cloud
storage bucket as a kind of vaults which
we are going to have the runtime
function lookup and pull in the secrets
as needed here we have a little bit of
bash magic in the first couple lines of
the slide which is looking up a cloud
storage bucket that is specific to an
environment using a little trick for
dynamic variable names in bash this
bucket name is then passed into the
function or cloud run service or App
Engine app when you deploy it so that
when those things start up they can load
the secret and keep it in memory to
reuse for further requests in the future
now with all this talk
of giving permissions and roles to a
service account with keys exported to
another system there's a lot of access
there you're still exposing even though
you're trying to get a leased access
approach being able to deploy to
production is not a trivial thing and
there are a number of ways you might
approach that since we're using Gil lab
you might take the open-source version
of git lab and host that on gke and I
believe there's a a codelab session for
that on Thursday exploring how to do
that but one approach that that Perry
and the into the woods team is exploring
here is splitting up the
responsibilities of what different
systems will do Gil lab can be
responsible for everything up for QA and
maybe cloud bills will handle all the
operations for staging and production
since so many of our operations are
wrapped up in bash scripts they can be
easily executed by any runner and so
gitlab is going to perform the same
operations as cloud builds through the
lens of those scripts and so as we've
built out the additional stages we might
even add deployment and an acceptance
stage for those end-to-end tests let's
go ahead and see if that demo from the
start of the talk has completed and we
have a successfully deployed service
so here is the gitlab CI pipeline that
we started earlier and now we see we
have some green check boxes and the last
one here where the exclamation mark
looks like an accepted failure but I'm
not too worried about that right now I
want to see did my QA environment get
updated from this change and looking
into this terminal output from the CI
system it looks like it ran through all
the steps figured out in environments
and deployed to a demo environment and
here we have a URL to look at our cloud
run service
well that command disappeared didn't it
well since Cloudland services deploy in
an authenticated only way I don't have
that command handy we will move on go
back to the slides please
all right so now that they have the
whole sei CD pipeline setup what have
they learned along the way
well first jr. James he was a bit
concerned about this CSE D there will be
a lot of bureaucracy he's happy that CSE
D actually helps him party who writes a
lot of these scripts she sees that mono
repo that adds complexity in the scripts
but it is worth it also secrets
management is always tricky the tests
notes that serverless makes the ICD
easier because you can test in
environments that are exact carbon
copies of your production environment
environments and also those environments
don't cost anything if they're not
running finally Tseng is really happy
that they can release software more
predictably
[Music]